hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast Tazz 9 based genome
engineering it is presented by Alejandro
Chavez MD PhD an assistant professor of
pathology and cell biology at the
Columbia University
Irving Medical Center I am to do work of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Chavez I will now turn the presentation
over to him hello my name is Alex happy
to be here today and I'm a correlation
professor at Columbia University I'd
like to share with you my work on cass
time-based genome engineering so
overview of my talk I'll tell you first
what is Cass 9 make sure that we're on
the same page I'll then tell you some of
our labs innovations with past 9
including our work on delete a spine
activators tuning guide RNAs and then
our guidepost donor strategy so what is
cass 9 cass signs a nucleus that's
directed to DNA the a small little RNA
the RNA is called a guide RNA and the
guide ernie contains 20 nucleotides a
couple in teri towards a target style
you want cass time to go towards cass
I'm the guy
anything complex together and don't bind
DNA once cast I in the gutter they are
bound to DNA test I will clean both the
DNA strands so what else can you do with
cast iron I wasn't cutting DNA well if
you mutate the residues in the protein
that are involved that DNA cutting you
can make what's called d cast 9 or Dead
cast 9 so dead cats 9 is still able to
bind DNA but it won't cut it and so in
the lab we kind of create D cast 9 to
molecular couch potato so go wherever
you want it'll sit there like a lump you
just not gonna do anything you can then
direct this little couch potato upstream
of a given genes promoter and by fusing
a very effective domains to D cast 9
such as domains required for gene
activation or for gene repression you
can actually now regulate that genes
transcription so why should you care
about the cast 9 and in particular
dcashman activators well they're really
useful for understanding fundamental
biology so let's say you want to look
for suppressors or enhancers of
phenotype in this case imagine you have
a fly has a normal eye morphology
express some poly glutamine track
protein within the eye you can see the
eye loses a lot of its morphology and
then if you wanna look for suppressors
of that phenotype use cast iron
activators to try to find one in this
case your stress hsp70 within those eyes
that also Express the poly glutamine
protein you see a nice rescue phenotype
addition activators let you model
disease filling model things like
gain-of-function mutations within genes
or gene amplification such as a current
cancer and then finally they're very
used for things like cellular
differentiation so in this case magic
Eventide guest cell and you've all
converge to different sorts of neurons
that read a lot of times requires
multiple transcription factors and you
can imagine using cosine activators to
turn on whatever selective portion of
transcription factors you want to allow
for the differentiation to occur so when
we started this project was the current
state of cosine activators well they
were able to activate but they weren't
very potent and so here I'm showing you
ten different guide RNAs each against
the same gene and what you'll see is
that most of them turn on the genome
most like twofold threefold and so you
can't actually get more activation if
you combine several of them together but
even doing that it wasn't very good
and most you still got between five to
fifty fourteen activation so would an
ideal if cosine activator what would
that look like
well you want to talk with just one
guide RNA that's important you guys lets
you do things like genome-wide screens
in this case give one guy to any given
cell you want
you know title and also you want to do
robust gene activation turn on gene 1.1
fold is probably not super useful to you
and so he chose an ambitious goal of
about 100 fold induction for any given
gene that we chose as kind of like our
goal for the project so was our
experimental setup we identify
transcriptional activation domains for
the literature we then fused them to the
c-terminus of decals time and then we
tested these fusions and of course our
reporter assay the way the assay works
is you have a TD tomato fluorescent
reporter gene which is don't remove a
minimal scene beep rotor and then it has
a guide RNA binding site upstream of
that we then direct Das time plus the
activator to that reporter and if it's
able to turn the reporter on ourselves
turn red and then we can quantify the
amount of redness using just flow
cytometry and so what is our results our
screen look like on the y-axis someone
qualify for you mean fluorescence
intensity on the x-axis I'm showing you
all the different fusions we tried and
what you see is that here's the data and
that really only three fusions seems to
work very well and so inclusions from
this experiment were that most fusions
failed not that excited were conclusion
that VP 64 was a really really good
activator and that led to some problems
because the issue was that we needed to
improve on VP 64 because at the time we
started this project PP 64 was the known
best activator I was just surprised to
find that it was so good because
something doesn't Bend in 80s or 90s I
thought there's no way it can be that
good that was wrong so basically after
we got there's results we decided to
look at how genes are activated
naturally so you can get inspiration
from that figure out how we can improve
our system so how does it dodges
transcription work so in native systems
you actually have not just one
transcription factor binding to a
promoter you XEL dozens a binding to
given genes promoter and then those
transcription factors each interact with
a different portion of the transcription
machinery and by doing so they each
cooperatively recruit RNA pull and race
so for example if you have a promoter
that binds to elements you'll get very
weak a transcription the order that
binds four different transcription
factors they're gonna pull better on RNA
polymerase and that's will get more
transcription so we had a very simple
hypothesis and that was - we mimicked
this cooperative recruitment by simply
fusing more activational means
caste 9 so what does that look like so
we started by three best activation
domains
also kind of known as the only three
that actually worked which are be 64 be
65 in RTA and then we use the same
source reporter si this time on the x
assets x-axis I'm going to quantify for
you medium fluorescents and on the
y-axis I'm showing you some of the
initial single fusion as we tried and so
you see that they do activate the
recorder a little bit but when we fuse
them in combination or as a full triple
we see saw a much improved activation
there's one a temporal difference
between B be 64 alone versus B 64 and
the two other elements used to it and so
this was really promising but this is
just a synthetic target reporter gene so
he wanted to see what this looked like
burned Dodgers genes
so for endogenous target we decided to
use badger and so we want to get
repeated the same experiment this time
quantified by for you veg F induction on
the x-axis and once again the single
fusions they were able to turn a little
bit of edge upon the double fusions were
even better the triple fusion was rather
good and so once again is on a tenfold
difference and so for the remainder of
the talk I'll refer to this BB 64 PCC 5
RTA fusion as BPR or Viper because it's
kind of cool so we tested all did you
know a close eye we tested a few others
like neuro d1 in rocks f2 these are both
transcription factors and we compared
our activation with you be 64 versus
Viper and while you see in both cases is
that Viper is significantly better in DB
64 it's about twenty times better and
today I tested I don't know how many
dozens of a most i and by for you
basically is always better on beat
support
so activating one gene that activating
one key at time is really nice but if
you come from the church lab which is
where I did my postdoc George always
like fast you like having multiplex and
so the reason why multiplexing is
important is because cells don't
actually just do one thing at a time
when they see a stimulus they respond
with many different things so you know
if they see heat they don't just turn on
one gene they turn on whole families of
genes and so if you ever want to be
Alexi ask that level of biology we need
to have tools that let us do it and so
the test multiplexing we targeted four
genes at once and we these are the four
genes on the x-axis and when you have to
make the movie P 64 you see they get
turned on a little bit you activate
through my Viper they get turned out a
lot more it's about ten to thirty fold
difference between them and so sorry for
part one of my talk we design a new
synthetic activation domain and this
looks about 10 to 30
all improvement over the previous best
activator because Kippur and data that I
didn't show you we've showed that our
tool works not only in human cells which
is where we did the majority of our
experiments but also works in mice and
mouse cells fly cells and in new cells
and finally we actually at the end of
our story we use our custom activator to
convert stem cells interneurons just
showing you X and get nice functional
phenotypes using our tool and this paper
was published a while back in Nature
Methods so the second part of my talk
I'll tell you our work on tuned guide
RNAs so tune guide RNAs in doubt casts
time with single nucleotide specificity
and we actually can use our tuned guide
RNA strategy to do language is a little
bit unique which is provide mutations
from emerging within populations of
cells so let's talk a little bit about
casting specificity so cosine is a
really powerful tool but the problem is
that has difficulty discriminating
between two highly similar targets so
imagine you have two alleles one's a bad
allele and others a good a little they
differ by a single single nucleotide
polymorphism and what you want to do is
you want to test line cut the bad allele
but you wanted to leave the good illegal
along so you say no problem you just
give this else a guide RNA that's
perfectly compliment tearing into the
battle eel and what will happen because
I will cut it the issue you face is that
that same guide RNA is perfectly
complementarity to the bad allele will
still have only one mismatch than good
allele and likely caste I will still
will still cut the good allele so how do
you improve castling specificity so we
started to about this problem we
realized that cosine certainly tolerates
single mismatches fairly well we then
wondered if there are more mismatches if
this would then actually inhibit cosines
ability to cut this was kind of known in
the field and so we said can we exploit
this difference where more mismatches
eventually Peter outcast line activity
dry see somehow tune caste I have seen
building type specificity so we said
what if we started with a guide RNA that
wasn't actually perfectly complementary
to the battle so let's say you had one
mismatch the battle eel
well once again so here's a single
mismatch once again guess I probably
won't mind that mismatch and so likely
it'll cut the bad allele on the flipside
that same guy during the oxy has two
mismatches against the good allele it's
got one that's the common mismatch
that's mismatch on both targets by and
the second one which is the allele
mismatch that
unique to the good allele and so we
wondered if caste I would then actually
have trouble interacting through the
allele and actually not cut it so the
question now was does our deal really
work and so to test that we made two
variants of the 10:1 beta lactamase and
so one variant was s 68 in yellow was n
68 and these two alleles differ by
single nucleotide polymorphism we then
created a library of garni variants such
that each of them had a single mismatch
the s 68 oil and thus by definition
would have two mismatches to the N 68
allele okay and so we then screened our
library or hoping to find guys that
would cut the s 68 allele but leave the
NCCA totally all along that was our goal
and so when we did that screen we
identified several gun days that seem to
have that property from our screen and
we decided that seemed to be active on s
68 believe at 16 alone and suicided to
validate our results in e.coli and so we
did was we gave cells either s 68 around
68 alleles we then fed them either
control guide which targets nothing
inside the coli genome are what we call
it on tune guide this is a guy that is
perfectly complementary to s 68 and by
virtue of that only has a single
mismatch 2n 68 or our screen guides
these are guides that have one mismatch
to s 68 and then two mismatches m-68
battery through those into cells we've
quantified some growth what's important
for this assay to know is that if the
guy donate cuts the alleles the cells
grow very poorly and so we see is that
the control cells they grow very well
because the guy doesn't touch either the
lily leaves them along the nitrous
density defeat cells a nun tune guide
you see that both s60 and n60 alleles
both die and that's because the guide
basically kills them both doesn't really
discriminate between either of them but
he feed cells one of the screen guides
you actually see that the s 16 allele
sees a mark roast efficiency while the N
60 of allele containment cells don't
seem to mind it in this hints that our
system is actually specific for cutting
s and leaving that alone and so we named
these screen guides
tune guides because they're for their
high specificity because there are two
inch particular target so how can we use
a system for mutation prevention so we
starting to ourselves if tune guide our
names really did give cast lines single
base pair resolution you can actually
imagine designing a system such that
it's benign to wild-type cells
with normal genomes but when a cell gets
an undesired mutation it's designed such
like cast I will cut those mutant
alleles away from the population and by
doing so prevent those mutations
remember becoming fixed in the
population so to tune guider an exact
same able mutation prevention to test
that we loaded cells with our ten one
and sixty-eight allele and then what we
did is we grew them up overnight and
what's important to know is that some
other cells randomly after overnight
growth they'll convert the Essex t lee
the n6 t italy let's do the s 68 allele
and when they do that when you get the s
form of this allele it actually causes
the cells to become resistant to
ampicillin and so we can simply take
cells grow them overnight plate them to
ampicillin a plate and just count the
number of amp colonies that's a mark for
how many times the an allele converted
into the s and so we did was we loaded
cells of our control guide or and we got
a lot of deference overnight already
loaded them with a guy that was tuned in
selectively to only destroy s 68 alleles
but leave ncc alleles alone and after
overnight growth we found is basically
we got a thousandfold fewer colonies
arguing that our system was able to
actively cut any s6t allele that
immersion of population and so this was
really promising but again it was only a
single target so we needed to do more
and so to cut to the chase and cut out a
lot of experiments I'll just show you
kind of a really nice big picture
experiment where he did multiplex
mutation prevention so in this case we
took our tune györgy strategy and we
designed it to simultaneously prevents a
total of 44 mutations in two different
genes all at once and so fall on the
y-axis I want to qualify for you
mutation frequency and then I'm showing
you what can you teach your frequency of
these different alleles coming out
randomly in a population are the cells
that just have control guides in them so
there's no system trying to prevent
their occurrence no AC is that somebody
the alleles are very frequent training
in almost 60% of those cells and when
you then load a cell with the to guide
RNA system that's designed to read each
of these four mutations all at once you
basically see that you don't get any of
the indications emerging from the
population basically prevents them all
essentially to area DNA sequencing that
we use this these experiments so sorry
for part to my talk to guide Ernie's a
lot of cows I'm distributing highly
similar targets no you cut that bad
while leaving the good Ally alone and
you can actually use these two got rnase
naval a new form evolutionary control
which we like to call mutation
prevention and so basically lets you
kind of prevent any mutation from
becoming fixed in the population
once you've designed a system against it
I mean this paper was recently published
also alright and for the final part of
my talk I'll tell you about our work on
our guidepost donor strategy and this is
really a method for allowing us to
simultaneously make hundreds of cells
with program mutations all at once
and so a little bit of background as you
all know the world is just becoming
flushed with sequencing data worldwide
sequencing capacity seems to be doubling
about every seven months and right now
we sequence less than 1% of the human
population but in doing that we more
identified over 300 million human
singular type nucleotide polymorphisms
of those about 20 million are predicted
to college the amino acid changes within
proteins and so those are obviously
gonna be influencing our phenotype in
ways that we still don't actually know
nor we it will it really predict very
well in addition that's just in humans
but as we've the sequencing more of
other species we're also finding
hundreds of millions of snips within
them and so the issue is you know what
the majority these snips do no one has a
clue and we really need to start
building technologies to us address
those sort of questions so what is the
gold standard for testing the
significance of a snip well one is you
take a while to sell you then introduce
the mutation into that locus to make the
mutant you're trying to study and then
you compare the mutant cells in the
wild-type cells and you hope that mutant
cells have some phenotype distant from
the wild-type cells you can now
attribute to a mutation and so how do
you is it that people make these cell
lines nowadays well of course they use
cassadine into how to use cats 9 to make
these cell lines it's pretty
straightforward you take cells you give
them cast on you are cast 9 to your
locus of interest can find in by stye
locus of interest and it cuts the locus
then if you have bed the cells at the
same time and donor DNA molecule that
can be used to repair that break the
cell will grab that donor and use it as
a repair template and by doing so it'll
incorporate your change into the site so
what are the issues of cache line
engineering one while test line is
certainly powerful and it's probably
best to leave out there right now to
make genome modifications current
approaches are very slow because they
basically do one mutant variant at a
time so you take your time you build one
cell line after couple months
you then test it and so that's really
labor-intensive it's also rather costly
even though it's much obviously cheaper
than it's been it was several years ago
in addition once this clone is generated
you then are gonna test them also one at
a time and so at this rate it for
building mutants one at a time ever
testing them one at a time we're all
gonna be long gone before we test
hundreds of millions of snip sites just
out there and the hundreds of millions
maybe billions more eventually got to
discover over time so how do we bridge
this huge gap between the amount of
mutations are finding on sequencing data
and the amount we actually understand
and we want to test in the lab so it's
begin assist faculty catalog the effects
of genomic variance we need scalable
methods of generating thousands even
cell lines at once and also tracking
their fitness within a pooled fashion
because it doesn't help us like make
millions of cell lines at once but I
detest them one at a time that's not
super useful either
um until is the first step towards this
goal we decided to focus our technology
on very simple model eukaryote and
that's the East
we decided see can we use yeast to build
this sort of technology that allows make
thousand mutations all at once and also
tracked up the insights all at once so
the first thing we need to address is
why is it that current methods actually
don't scale to these hundreds of
thousands mutations at a time and so
when you're looking me to try to make
one single mutation in a Cell you were
going to take a guide RNA against look
this you want and then feed it the donor
against that locus that you want to have
it uses a repair template and the cells
will likely that get one guide Ernie
will probably get also a little bit of
the donor and that lets you have a very
high frequency of target mutation so
that's good it makes it very efficient
but now imagine you have a pool of guide
Ernie's no pool of donors so each guide
has a unique donor associated with it
well now just because a cell gets one
guy he may not actually get the proper
donor with it because of that your
frequency of getting the proper mutation
you want is actually very very low so
how is it that you prevent the
uncoupling between the guide RNA the
donor during transactions well the
answer is rather simple why not try to
fuse them together and so what have you
fed cells a library of plasmids so that
each library contains unique guide RNA
any donor that refused insist so
basically every single guide Ernie had
it's appropriate donor template right
with it then you could feed these guys
post donor plasmids to a cow sign
expressing cell line the Cassadine cell
line would get each one of the guys
close donor plasmids and now because of
the guy
donar are coupled the mutation frequency
would be very high you get a very
efficient conversion to the mutations
you wanted so we call it a strategy but
stoner strategy will describe how we
tested it X so in addition what are the
uses probably got close donor well
because every single mean cell line
carries a neat guy plus donor plasmid by
sequencing the prevalence of a given guy
close donor within the cell population
you can actually track its fitness so
imagine you have a starting population
of cells where two of them have red
guidepost donors to have green guy post
owners to have yellow and two of blue
you then select subject those cells that
make sure to experiment your special
condition and you get out the library at
the end in this case you see you have
two Reds five yellows and one blue well
what this means is that by sequencing
your starting library in any library you
can actually then understand what each
of these patients did to part fitness
and so for example in the start of this
experiment we had two green cells at the
experiment we had no green cells and so
what that tells you is that the green
mutations reduced is deleterious under
your experimental conditions and so
simply by sequencing the guidepost don't
you kind of can figure out the fitness
of all yourselves which is really useful
so how old is our method work well we
use our guidepost don't strategy to
these people mutations into a series of
low side and we tested three different
low side one at a time are 6 to 14 which
is non-coding region or that's just one
and stars 2 which are both coding
regions in the each genome and I'm going
to show you on the x-axis the efficiency
of conversion and what you see is
basically have about 80% efficiency of
conversion when we use our guidepost our
strategy with 80% of the colonies
arising post transformation having the
mutation we expect them to have that we
designed
we also a saw similar high efficiency
when we try to perform short 60 base
pair deletions within the genome or
short 15 base pair insertions within the
genome so it's kind of told us that our
strategy seems to be pretty plastic and
you can do more than just play mutations
you can do things like a small in Dells
which are also very stupid in the human
genome that many times you actually want
understand also so in choosing a
mutation that time works which is great
now the question is can we make several
mutations all at once in a mix pool
okay can we track each of the mutants
Fitness is simply by keeping silent
sequencing out the guidepost own and
fragment so to test this
a small library of guideposts under
plasmids they were directed against
either the arcs to 14-9 coding which is
kind of our control region of the genome
or s just one which is a protein
involved in DNA repair we then pulled
the guidepost daughter classes against
both arcs 240 minutes just long together
and we did a full transformation we then
drew the colleagues up either overnight
your regular conditions or we're not you
the credits of the DNA damaging agent
such that cells are made fresh just once
you grow more poorly and the president
DNA damaging agent wall cells that were
targeting against the non-coding region
shouldn't really care we then just
sequenced the prelate so the guy who was
donor classes then within each pool the
ones that grew up overnight [ __ ]
conditions versus the ones i grew up
overnight DNA damaging conditions and
then we compared the guy and plus donor
abundances between different conditions
and so what did our data look like
so in gray i'll show you the hearts 214
moons in red I'll show you just one
continues and on the y-axis here I'm
gonna show you the log tenfold change
and cells like through under drug
conditions versus no drug conditions and
so what you see is that cells that had
mutations against sgs1 that were
supposed to abolish this activity they
saw a marked decrease in their fitness
when growing in drug conditions for
salandrich conditions versus cells that
had guidepost donors are targeting ours
to 14 which should have no effect on the
Jamz responses they tended to grow much
better and so once again and also we
looked at themselves that deletions
that's just one or replacements that's
just one that we're supposed to
basically pull at these so that's just
went out and certain kind of junk
instead of it also grew poorly as you
expect since they're all destruction
it's just one function while doing the
same deletions or insertions into our
stoop our teen didn't have an effect and
so the thing you might be asking is well
Castine you think assigned to cut is
just one maybe all that's happiness test
she was just getting cut and destroyed
and that's why all these cells are
growing more poorly in the crystal DNA
damage a major it has nothing to do with
the fact they're actually making the
changes we want to make and so to test
that we did what we call a recode and so
basically we had a guy close donor that
was designed to cut it's just one and
rather than disrupting the allele simply
would change the coding for the amino
acids so one also the amino acid
composition it would just change the DNA
sequence but lemon juicing only some
modifications the way you see that that
the recoating is just one had no effect
on DNA damage sensitivity arguing that
our system is actually specific for not
only cutting
just one but also replacing it as we
intend and so this was really great we
were excited that I mixed pulled work
and so now the next thing to do is see
what kind of fun things we can do with
this art technology and so one of the
first things we did was we did a talent
deletion series along as just one and so
we made a library of 60 base pair
deletions we finished just one along the
Tyra gene and so on the bottom here I'm
showing you what that's just one gene
looks like it has several different
domains that are important for its
activity one it's got a top three
binding domain that's required for it to
director the essential topoisomerase
type 3 protein which is request just
won't do its function there's a domain
with it's just one that sees the
helicase domain that's required first
just want to be a helicase and service
functions engineer repair and fathers
are QC domain which is just one uses to
bind your protein structures during its
roles in DNA repair and the blue dots
I'll show you guys donors that were
designed to delete 60 base pair
fragments from this just one genome at
different portions of the gene and then
I'm the orange dots I'll show you guys
that were guessed as just one but
instead of having a donor that's
supposed to replace a piece of [ __ ]
spawn these had a chunk donors so
essentially these should kind of like do
nothing to the cell and so on the y-axis
I will show you log tenfold change on
cells that are growing in drug versus no
drug condition and once again what we
see is that there are the blue dots
there some that get depleted in
particular the regions that's just one
that correspond to the top three the
helicase knocked EC binding domain these
need to be less bit when deletions are
cost within them versus deletions with
any other part of the protein which is
order which is kind of known from
previous literature in addition the guys
that were against that's just one but
didn't have a donor to cause a deletion
basically they didn't see any fitness
effects between the drug and no drug
condition so what I'll making for
mutations which is another thing you
want to do with our system so a test die
we took us just one again and we
targeted several conservative as users
then that's just one can we change all
that cancer residue to all other
residues but for the sake of clarity I'm
just gonna show you two of those changes
in this case I'll show you data for
converting the residues to either
alanine or isoleucine and then we tested
the fitness of each of these mutants
using a range of different DNA imaging
agent concentrations either the lowest
knowledge just by millimolar hydroxyurea
or the highest amount which is
40-million molar hydroxyurea and that's
just one by the way is required
for resistance to this drug once again I
managed to offer you log 10 ball change
and drug versus no door condition and
what we see we easily get all the
results we expect and so to walk you
through some of them we see that if you
add more drug which is the dark blue
dots the cells tend to be more sick they
have you got less drug so this is
expected because it sells their mutant
precious one these lowest I should grow
less well as the amount of drug
increases and you you take these
conserved residues in the protein
addition if you meet a pic lysine 706
which is that critical catalytic residue
within the helicase as you see the cells
don't like it and that's expected you
change to alanine or which is use a kind
of benign or isoleucine it doesn't
really matter the cells don't like it
you throw in DNA damage agent throughout
happy if you change Baily 958 so
isoleucine you see that cells don't
really care and that kind of makes sense
because baleen isoleucine are highly
similar to each other if you mutate a
charged residue to an uncharged residue
so you take glutamine 986 and convert
isoleucine you see that that's very
deleterious and so once again basically
kind of saw all the expected results you
would anticipate when you do these
mutations and so it kind of helps us
know that your system seemed to be
working as we expected so we had done a
lot of experiments now on a single gene
but we were really interested in knowing
can you do this a user sort of system on
genome-wide scales and so to test that
we generate a new guy post donor library
that was designed to basically mutate
all 300 small open reading frames or
smores within the east genome and so
what our s'mores s'mores are open
reading frames are less than hundred
meters in length so it's funny is that
classically open reading frames have
been defined as being a hundred Mino
acids and larger but that's an arbitrary
number there's no reason why a protein
can't be shorter than that and so
actually smarts tend to be rather
neglected in the biological space and so
he thought this is a good opportunity I
tried and their function better and so
like I said they're poorly studied but
it's interesting about s'mores is that
over time we're saying I learned thanks
to have very important biological roles
as Morris actually are some are known
text to be essential especially an even
higher level organisms and so we thought
this could be a really cool idea
opportunity to actually start to
understand what they might be doing and
so in addition to making a smart library
within that library also included
several gradualist donors against both
essential and non-essential ORFs
and so the first question we asked is
simply wished marks or are there any
smarts frankly that are central from
viability in use and so the test that we
transformed our library into East and
then we compared the abundance of the
guidepost donor plasmids and cells that
either did or didn't express cats nine
what we saw is that we targeted the
non-essential horse basically there is
no depletion of any given guideposts
donor and cast line expressing versus
non cast line express themselves and
that makes sense because if you mutate
these non non central open reading
frames the cells don't really mind you
on the flip side if you target essential
horse you see that there's a marked
depletion and GEICO's donors that are
against those in the cast I'm expressing
cells versus the non can express
themselves which is exactly you'd expect
guitar game gina's essential for growth
they're not gonna grow and finally we
targeted smores we were kind of excited
to see that there was a small subset of
sports that actually appeared to be
essential for the cells to grow um
well their vast majority of smarts
though appear to also to not be
essential so still whose interesting
result so the next thing we asked is
what other roles might exist for s'mores
and so to do that we subjected our
library it's multiple different
conditions we grew them at higher
temperatures we grew them in the
president Jeannie damaging agent or we
treated them with the antifungal
fluconazole and what you can see is
basically that s'mores
there's muse of smoke beans to basically
ultra sensitivity in all these different
situations arguing the small sexy play
significant biological roles a lot of
different contexts and so this really
suggested that Smurfs really have global
roles that are yet to be discovered in
them it's it's actually an interesting
space of biology that we surely start
exploring more so sorry for part three
of my talk basically there's hundreds of
millions of unsightly snips out there
the guy throws donor strategies a way to
actually simultaneously generate
hundreds of thousands of mutants at a
time and actually track their fitness
and you can use them to either study a
single protein or you can use them to
exam entire families of proteins across
the whole genome and we were lucky that
the paper recently got accepted for
publication Nature Biotechnology and
press soon without like to thank a few
people so I've had some really amazing
collaborators over my time and four in
particular for the Casa activator work I
like to think John Shimon and Sue Laura
which are postdoc and grad student in
the lab respectively that really helped
for set project for addition been fruit
was instrum
so in the two got RNA work he was a
staff scientist for these when I was
there and then Xiaogang whoa and Angela
tongue were really critical in making
the guidepost donor strategy as amazing
as it became in the end they really
shall really did a good job believe that
project over the course of several years
because technology was not easy to get
to work as we would expect in our
current funding sources like I think
those also which is Kobe University
answer the Burroughs welcome
with that I'll take any questions thank
you Alex that informative program will
now start the live tiny portion of the
webinar if you have a question my going
to do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button what
answers many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started first
question is EPR appears to be one of
several Kaz nine activator systems is
there a best system so I get that
question basically every time I give
this talk and basically what happened is
several years ago I got tired of getting
that question and so what we did was
actually we decided to compare all their
factors together we compared there's
about 17 activators now they've been
published there might even be more over
time I've kind of lost track of them
frankly and basically when you compare
VIPRE against multiple different
activators it tends to be one of the top
three best the three best are Sam Viper
and Sontag and actually we ended up
publishing this work because we thought
was really important so there's a later
paper that people should look at others
potion Nature Methods
that has my name on it he's got to find
it the basically kind of compares the
different activators together and we
think that's currently the best data
exists out there to really help people
answer this question of what's the best
activator which interests in use for
their studies thank you given your
experiments can you predict what
mutations you need to introduce into a
guide RNA in order to give it a lil
specificity yeah so this question is
referring to the tune guide RNA strategy
in that strategy we introduce mutations
into the guide and by doing so we hope
to have it has specificity towards one
allele but not another
and so obviously one of the things that
we would love to do is be able to
predict what the mutation should be very
intrusive to the guide to give it that
specificity it turns out from the amount
of experiments that we've done which is
really annoying made about five tune
guides I don't really think we're
capable of predicting the rules other
people look at my data and they think
they know the rule is but I just don't
feel comfortable making assumptions on
the no5 um it would be interesting to
try to do a larger scale analysis try
understand what the rules are but at
this stage we have it thank you
have you tried your guide Plus donor
method with human cells short answer is
no there's we literally just got the guy
posed our method working pretty well on
nice recently one of the areas that you
think would be interesting exploring
human cells but we do think there's a
lot of reasons why it's pretty much more
challenging for human cells but as of
now we haven't tried it um I would
anticipate it would work very poorly but
I don't know the true answer thank you
we have time for one more question
there are now multiple Kaz nine mutants
that have improved specificity have you
tried to see if they give allele level
specificity yeah so this is once again
referring to mutation prevention stuff
so there's no wow maybe this is five
different hands cast knight variants
that I I'm aware of there's probably
even more in literature we had actually
tried a couple years ago to the enhanced
cast nine variants to see if they would
give us a little specificity similar to
the tune guides at least in our hands
they didn't that's not to be said that
they could never could there's now like
I said additional ones which I think
would be interesting a test and we kind
of think that maybe like those enhanced
cast on parents I think are very good
for making cast eye not touch things
that have like four or five or three
mismatches but they may not be allele at
level alleles little sensitivity um so
we're kind of wondering if maybe in the
future we'll be some combination of two
guys plus and ask a Stein variance which
your lucky blocks me hit that space
easier and more reproducibly
but for now at least what we've tried in
the experience has really helped solve
the problem thank you for that I would
like to once again thank Alex for his
presentation but also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August
31st 2018 you'll receive an email from
laggards letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon
goodbye